maintenant une question qui est très
intéressante c'est pourquoi est-ce que
ça
[Musique]
nous sommes à londres
hier a eu lieu le pack de excusez moi
j'étais à la caméra même temps ça bouge
un petit peu fière gülen pack de samsung
avec la présentation des galaxy s 10 là
là ça va mieux galaxy s 10 et se disent
plus s10e galaxie buzz et galaxy watch
galaxy ou fit et galaxy fold galaxie
folle c'est le smartphone qu'on avait
attendu en tout cas sous le nom samsung
axes x pendant des années qui s'est
ensuite appelé samsung galaxy f et qui
en réalité s'appelle samsung galaxy
folle folle pliable voilà on comprendra
aisément alors ce smartphone était
montre en catimini ou 20 novembre
dernier novembre je crois dans la
conférence des développeurs de samsung
on a vu le grand écran intérieur on a vu
un écran extérieur
pas plus très peu lumière est là il a
été montré tout au début de la
conférence développeurs ils sont pas
étendus ils sont vie allez on commence
par ça on est au début comme ça on n'en
parle plus c'est fait et on en reparle
un peu plus tard alors il ya plein de
choses à dire dessus
déjà au niveau du smartphone en lui-même
on le voit on comprend un peu sur l'adn
de quelle manière il est conçu quoi il
va ressembler ce qui peut nous apporter
on entend un grand écran intérieur on
voit un écran extérieur
il ya plein de questions qui se posent
pourquoi est ce que samsung ne
présentent tout de suite rapidement au
début ça c'est fait maintenant on passe
à la gamme s disent pourquoi maintenant
ça soulève plein de questions ça
justement on va le faire là on est à
londres à l'hôtel de curtains vous en ai
parlé hier dans ma vidéo de présentation
à des samsung galaxy s 10 ce que je vous
propose c'est mon fils de londres on
prend l'eurostar retour à paris et on en
parle davantage
ouais de temps mais qui bosse mais
écoute il faut bien préparer des choses
on ne peut pas tous être comme ça on va
en intel a profité à un moment la vraie
vie nous rattrape
bonjour comment allez vous aujourd'hui à
londres
là il fait un temps magnifique là alors
moi j'ai une question
si vous permettez je voudrais savoir
dans cette voiture qui a vu harry potter
harry potter 6 et tous utilisent à tous
sur dix mille fois est ce que tu
pourrais comprendre que quelqu'un n'est
pas vu harry potter dans cette voiture
en 2019 harry potter également ce trône
c'est très grave voilà je vois il peut
le voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut pas venir à londres et à la gare
st pancras sans forcément penser harry
potter et l avoine 9,3 car si vous
connaissez qui est juste là karim est
revenue il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
regardé à les potters cette barre est un
moteur au moment mur là maintenant vous
regardez cette vidéo elle aura vu harry
potter n'aura bus resteraient c'est ça
la voix de la voix le feu et le rac 1 à
établir la famille on voit ça on voyait
dans la boutique elle va s'acheter un
lobby avec les plus qui vont avec nous
qu'elle est qu'aujourd'hui je fais une
vidéo sur le galaxy fold c'est en penses
quoi toi basse et ça se plie séquence où
ses chars il ya des bordures ouais avoir
avoir avoir mes oies quand même deux
mille ballons mais quand même de me baï
sa faiblesse a fait des émules d'al quoi
ça fait vite vague deux fois mais le
ballon fait deux fois je vais même
quatre fois 100 france à son bassiste
offrant coup arriver à paris on a plein
de choses à se dire sur ce smartphone de
chez samsung le design sa smart phones
cas ces pays sans s'en douter avec un
smartphone à écran plat on savait que
forcément ça allait être épais ça vous
pouvez pas y couper
vous avez à l'avant sur la grande phase
avant l'écran de 4,6 pouces amoled et
une fois que vous l'ouvrez à l'intérieur
en écran de 7,3 pouces
infiniti flex display rien qu'en le
regardant comme ça à l'extérieur il ya
un truc un peu bizarre c'est à dire que
pourquoi est ce que samsung nous a fait
un petit écran sur la face avant alors
qu on a vachement places perdues
c'est assez bizarre d'autant plus qu'on
a juste une petite caméra sur le haut et
absolument rien d'autre on a donc un
gros smartphone avec un petit écran une
petite caméra et c'est tout c'est très
bizarre c'est très déséquilibrée et vu
qu'aujourd'hui on a des smartphones avec
des très grands écrans qui sont
quasiment bord à bord sur trop avec ça
c'est quand même un peu gênant mais
c'est pas tout parce que lorsque vous
l'ouvrez alors effectivement là le 7,3
poussé l'effet waouh ça ce pli c'est
magnifique c'est pas comme le smartphone
du royaume le flex paille vous avez une
espèce de grosse partie centrale quand
il se farde qui est vraiment mal fini là
par contre c'est vraiment très
harmonieux c'est très beau par contre
je comprends pas cette idée d'avoir
cette grosse encore bruce découle sur le
côté alors que sur le galaxy s 10 plus
ils nous ont fait une bulle
c'est un petit rond qui attaque très
bien les deux caméras et j'imagine tous
les capteurs qu'on va retrouver dans ce
smartphone pourquoi est-ce que sur grand
écran sur cette grande partie on a en
hausse est énorme en coche on voit les
deux caméras puis tout une grande partie
noire sur le côté c'est assez bizarre on
a l'impression qu'au final c'est pas
bien finie ou alors que ça a été
vraiment été développée sans tenir
compte des techno actuelle sans tenir
compte des samsung galaxy s 10 plus
qu'il intègre beaucoup mieux en tout cas
c'est de caméra sur la face avant autre
pan qui est assez surprenant c'est
qu'effectivement alors ça c'est
peut-être une une question technique
c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'à des
bords qui sont assez épais par rapport
notamment à ce qu'on retrouve sur des
smartphones comme le galaxy s 10 16 10
plus voilà tout ça c'est des questions
un peu design mais ça serait vachement
de questions quant à la conception de ce
produit sous le capot ça devrait a
priori tourner on va voir un sort gravé
en 7 nanomètres 12 igad ram 512 giga de
stockage probablement extensible une
expérience audio il sera forcément
immersive avec des haut-parleurs stéréo
signé à kg un truc hyper fluide eau pour
faire du multitâche jusqu'à trois
applications multi tasking alors ça peut
être rigolo mais on va perdre un petit
peu l'intérêt d'avoir ce grand écran
pour vraiment avant tout hyper
confortable lecture si vous faites
tourner trois applications en même temps
ou pourquoi pas on peut le faire
éventuellement mais à mon avis c'est
palladienne forcément de ce produit
parce que ce qui va être vraiment
intéressant c'est d'avoir ce grand écran
17.3 pouces c'est profiter d'un confort
pour travailler pour regarder mais ça on
en parle juste après lorsque vous êtes
par exemple sur l'écran extérieurs
notamment sur google maps hop vous
l'ouvrez ça vous ou votre google maps en
grand c'est plus immersif en termes
d'autonomie
ils ont mis en gros deux batteries donc
je pense une part côté pour gagner déjà
en épaisseur on un total de 4000 380
millions perreur un smartphone comme ça
vous en doutez avec ses deux écrans il
faut le nourrir si vous voulez avoir une
autonomie correcte il faut forcément des
batteries un peu boosté donc ça
effectivement avoir lorsqu'on le testera
ultérieurement au truc assez intéressant
point de vue technique c'est que lorsque
le concept a été lancé je me suis
demandé comment ils vont intégrer les
caméras à l'eau final nous ont fait six
caméras une à l'avant lorsque votre
smartphone y est
fermé pour pouvoir vous faire du skype
discuter ou faire un selphy pourquoi pas
trois caméras à l'arrière j'imagine
qu'on retrouve sensiblement les mêmes
caméras que sur le galaxy s ii et ace 10
plus une 12 mégapixels un peu standard
une 12 mégapixels et l'objectif x 2 et
une 16 mégapixels grand-angle
probablement à la 123 degrés à
l'intérieur lorsque vous l'avez ouvert
deux caméras probablement les mêmes
caméras qu'on pourra trouver dans le
galaxy s 10 plus haut niveau de la
caméra de ses films un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est située
sur le côté pour venir déverrouiller
assez facilement en prenant en main
c'est à dire de la boîte qui nous ont
montré qu'ils ont une grosse coque de
protection parce que c'est aussi la
question comment je les protéger ce
smartphone à smartphone qui sera dispo à
partir du 3 mai prochain au tarif de
2000 euros c'est très cher c'est très
cher de l'autre côté c'est le début je
pense que samsung va tester un peu le
marché voir si derrière ça répond si les
gens sont intéressés piras serez vous
dans quelques années les prix vont
forcément baisser dès lors que plus de
personnes viendront d'eux fut dès lors
que plus d'innovation des dortoirs plus
de concurrence donc pour l'instant ça
reste quand même un marché de niche tout
le monde va pas lui ce que je retiens
vraiment quand je vois ce smartphone
j'ai l'impression que c'est un concept
qui est pas complètement beauty on est
sur une première version il fallait le
sortir il ya un moment il faut avancer
il faut y aller j'imagine que d'ici un
an à deux ans avec en plus la
concurrence qui va pousser à côté on
devrait voir un smartphone beaucoup plus
beaux beaucoup plus intégrées parce que
je reste convaincu que c'est l'avenir de
la téléphonie mobile c'est l'avenir du
smartphone d'avoir ces grands écrans
pliables plus de confort pour travailler
imaginez vous bossez par exemple en
traitement de texte word ou alors
croient pas du excel du powerpoint vous
bossez sur une sur une présentation sur
un écran si la de 3 pouces et d'un
moment où vos yeux ou mal l'assurance
est de 8,3 c'est quand même un peu plus
confortable plus cool pour lire des
articles par exemple vous voulez lire
votre journal en ligne guerre de l'actu
on imagine que les polices de caractères
sont plus grandes on va moins se faire
mal aussi ça c'est aussi intéressant
pour regarder des vidéos un meilleur
confort et pour jouer à des jeux aussi
plus intéressant parce qu'on aura un
écran qui sera plus grand c'est
maintenant une question qui est très
intéressante c'est pourquoi est-ce que
ça me saoule nous a présenté ce
smartphone tout au début de la
conférence
je pensais qu'ils allaient le garder un
peu pour la fin offre replace non on a
l'impression qu'ils ont présentée
directement les enfants voilà on en
parle c'est fait maintenant on peut
passer à l'acte us l'on peut passer à
nos smartphones du moment à ce qui nous
intéresse pour
lesquels on est en réalité venu alors
que le galaxy fold on voyait très
clairement qu'on n'était pas venu là
pour ça mais qu'il fallait en parler
je pense notamment parce que wade a
présenté le sien dit si normalement
quelques jours au mwc samsung étaient
pressés de présenter sa copie alors
qu'au final s'il n'y avait pas eu tant
de pression derrière
à mon avis il aura attendu avons nous
entendu parler un peu plus tard mais
l'actu faisant ils étaient un petit peu
obligé c'est assez drôle de commencer
comme ça on n'était pas prêt je dis bon
ben on va commencer et généralement on
commence à parler du marché savoir
comment se porte la marque quelle est
leur part de marché et gnagnagna
là on n'arrivait pas directement dessus
à la limite pourquoi pas en plus ce qui
est assez intéressante on est sur un
smartphone qui est très très fort c'est
l'avenir et ils le disent très
clairement c'est l'avenir de la
téléphonie mobile pourquoi est-ce que ça
n'aide pas dj co qui arrivaient
directement présentant sans qu avoir un
sens il n'y a pas d'interrogation est ce
que samsung nous fera une présentation
ultérieurement un peu plus forte
est-ce qu'ils vont attendre plutôt une
version 2 de ce smartphone pour vraiment
faire une keynote dédiée
il ya plein d'interrogations je pense
que pour l'instant ils vont tester le
marché voir un petit peu ce que ça dit
voir un peu les retourner d'y avoir un
peu les retours au niveau du grand
public
est ce que le grand public est pris à
l'acheter oui ou non est ce que c'est un
marché de niche que ça va vraiment se
développer et démocratiser
c'est plein de questions qui sont un
terreau est un hyper intéressant
d'ailleurs je compte sur vous pour dire
ce que vous en pensez un banc
commentaires on en a parlé depuis très
longtemps ses smartphones à écran
pliable
je vous en parle énormément je trouve ça
vraiment hyper hyper hyper intéressant
maintenant ça commence
il est arrivé j'ai pas encore une raison
de le prendre dans les mains cette année
ça sera le cas donc ne reparlera bien
évidemment en attendant vous de ce que
vous avez pu voir qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
est-ce que ce smartphone vous pensez
comme moi pour l'instant c'est bien une
belle technos avance mais reste un peu
sur notre faim en terme de design même
si effectivement pour les usages ça a
l'air super intéressant dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire et bien
évidemment on va rester connecté on va
reparler et on va aller voir ce qui se
passe du côté de chez huawei du côté de
chez xiaomi très très prochainement donc
vous invite à faire une seule chose
c'est à vous abonner du sila je vous
embrasse polissage corp
[Musique]